When you talk about replicating this team?
I don't I don't know if it's possible
[if] I could start from scratch and said I want to I want to duplicate the warriors
[I] don't think I could do it the warriors had plans and [ideas] and
the initial ones
Almost none of them came through to make this team it took some [luck] [probably] sounds a lot easier than it that it is
Stars was really not [behind] there's a blueprint for a championship team here
But I'm not sure [that] it's one that any other team could then try to replicate
It has to be remembered there wasn't a whole lot [of] pride in this warriors organization. No single event
Illustrated how far the warriors had Fallen as the night that they came together to retire Chris Mullins jersey?
They just traded another one of their favorites Monta Ellis these are the fans who had seen
Player after player who had passed through gone on to greatness
elsewhere and a lot of people thought [that] this was just an attention grab and so they let Joe lake of have it and
If they looked a little more closely and maybe studied Chris mullins reaction that night. They would have seen this is the beginning of something
Everything work out. Just fine. Just a little bit of patience use that passion
most Elite NBA teams you can kind of see them coming from a distance because
They just grab that big flashy star free-agent
or they [just] got the number one overall [pick] the warriors never did any of that if
The warriors are a championship team of what ifs then steph curry their MVP is the biggest
What-if of all there's nobody in the NBA like them there's nobody in the world
Like it for me to get a chance firsthand to see him
Coming out of college people knew this guy is a great shooter
But they weren't sure what his NBa position was is he really a playmaker is he too skinny all of these questions hovered over him
Ricky Rubio
Johnny Flynn from Syracuse University
Step and Courage still available the Golden State Warriors select
Stefan [curry] from Davidson
It's not like the warriors of that moment stopped everything had a big party. We got a future MVP. Physically could he hold up
ankle injuries the Riders career
Heartbreaking is all I can say as a result of him not being on the floor a whole lot
They were able to get yet another lottery pick [a] lot of the buzz that night was about Jimmer Mania
Maybe the most talked-about player in this trap when I saw Jimmer go front of me
I was happy [for] I started
Oh, but I'm a little nervous cuz you know you don't know we're gonna be slotted at the star has a line
I was the very next pick Klay Thompson from Washington State
University San Chandler
But he turned them down to join the New York Knicks they then put an offer sheet out for restricted free agent deandre Jordan
That didn't work
Andrew bogut at that time to a lot of people was looked at as just [another] bust the warriors traded Monta Ellis a fan
Favorite for an Andrew bogut who wasn't even playing at the time. He was injured
This is the first guy they brought in who really thought defense first
Harrison Barnes was expected to be a shrewd choice, but there wasn't a whole [lot] of excitement the [feeling] was that
Harrison had actually been better as a freshman and so that was a nice [pickup]
But nobody saw the second-round pick becoming the player that he has become
Draymond [Green] terrific player in the second round shocking that he would get there to it
But these drafts sometimes go unexpected a second-round pick 35th overall so by definition. You're not expecting stardom
emotionally the driving Force of this team and the
Conscience of this team as [far] as how it needs to play to be able to come and blend in with these guys and you
Know try to do what I can do to help this team out
You could tell [it] was a brotherhood brewing from the start and it's been something special. That's
Happened over the course of these last four years for me
2013 saw a lot of things break their way as well to sit across [from] an elite player
Who had many options to hear him say?
You guys are building something that I want to be a part of that moment for us as an organization was a big one
There were a lot of question marks around
Andre Iguodala a starter for his entire career had never come off the bench exactly how would he fit in?
They're still looking for upgrades and Dwight Howard
had several options certainly considered the warriors, but he ends up choosing the Houston rockets, so the warriors stand pat and
Might have even dodged a bullet the summer of 2014 was almost as poor to [attest] as the summer of 2013
Let's start with the fact that they nearly upset the clippers ultimately if they win the game 7 and go to the second round
It would have been awfully hard
To fire mark Jackson at that point the fact of the matter is Steve Kerr was not number one on their list
Stan van Gundy [was]
the toughest thing about
Taking the warriors job was turning Phil Jackson down. [I] had told him if we can work out a contract
I'm coming to New York [that] was right when the warriors came in and interviewed me
There was so much talent on the golden state roster and not as much on the knicks roster frankly, but I knew immediately
That's where I wanted to be
I just thought it was a perfect fit [for] the personnel that the warriors already had
One the things you wanted to make sure was that we had the trust of our players
[I] can tell you how to bring my for the game such a great shooter his career
You can teach [me] little nuances about shooting. It can really expand my game, and I just knew get a vision
By the summer of 2014 the warriors know they have something special with Steph curry and Klay thompson
But they're missing some element in the frontcourt
And so they're looking at Kevin love who's looking to get out of Minnesota [the] trade of Klay Thompson for Kevin love
Made a lot of sense, so there was a heated debate among warriors officials about whether to make that deal
But in the end the keep Klay thompson
Forces one out
Was in love with NBA growing up the business side was new to me it came out like you had something to prove
I'd be wondering what the NBa record is for most points in a quarter you just watched it. I?
Just saw the potential how well guys were fitting together?
That was a huge [game-changer] as far as how this team operated. It was a long path every single year
I was with the new team
there wasn't anybody who would have ever said you know this is a guy who one day is gonna be the key member of a
championship bench
coming in we all didn't know exactly what to [expect] [you] [could] tell that we were trending in the right direction and we
Starting to put it together and figure some things out as that first season was going on you could see that Trust building
There was a moment when I looked around
I said you [noticed] our team is going to be amazing if curry had been a star on day one
If there's never any ankle injuries the warriors don't have the opportunity to get Klay thompson and Harrison Barnes in the first place and maybe
Several others, and I'm not satisfied just winning one this team. Definitely has a lot of room for growth. Good luck trying to do something
similar